cuál es el primer pensamiento que
aparece cuando vemos estas imágenes
cuál es la primera emoción
eso me puedo imaginar que debe ser algo
como
qué lindo qué belleza y si es verdad son
muy hermosos
pero también hay otra realidad lo que
pasa es que nadie te la dice nos
muestran una sola cara de la moneda y
claro si no no nos reproducir y amos
quien en forma consciente sometería su
vida a un pequeño tirano que te demanda
las 24/7
las 24 horas del día los 7 días de la
semana
un tipo del que hay que alimentar vestir
bañar y que si te descuidas te hace pis
en la cara
es por eso que generación tras
generación nos cuentan y contamos lo
hermoso que son los bebés
nos metemos en una bolsa mental de
acuerdo a nuestro sistema de creencias y
lo dejamos ahí porque ahí va
sistema de creencias que es justamente
crea nuestra realidad y nos hace tomar
acción sin verse habrá otra posibilidad
si habrán lo vivido otra forma de
vivirlo
es que no estamos acostumbrados a dudar
de aquello en lo que creemos
el dinero se gana con sacrificio y ahí
anda sacrificándonos por la vida
mientras que el de al lado está ganando
dinero viajando
tenés que estudiar para hacer alguien en
la vida
ser alguien en la vida
y ahí andamos con tus culpas cuando no
encontraste nada que te guste para
estudiar y ahora no sabes quién sos
aparte de un nadie
los negros se visten de celeste las
nenas se visten de rosa parece una
pavada pero anda la puerta de cualquier
colegio y te puedo asegurar que la mayor
parte de los chicos va a estar vestido
con esos colores
sobre todo los más chiquitos que es
donde más daño hacemos los papás las
medidas también están armadas con esos
colores como si los colores estuvieran
géneros
como si realmente hubiera cosas de
chicas y cosas de chicos
y a ver no estoy diciendo que esto esté
mal lo que estoy diciendo es que vivimos
tan inmersos en nuestras creencias que
vamos por la vida creyendo que es así
sin darnos el tiempo para ver si puede o
no ser de otra manera
estamos hablando de modelos
yo como algunos de ustedes sabrán soy
coach ontológico profesional
los coaches trabajamos con el lenguaje
uno de nuestros postulados es que si no
está en el lenguaje no existe pensemos
juntos realmente se les ocurre algo que
exista pero no nombremos
todo está en el lenguaje toda nueva
creación necesita una palabra que la
defina
por ejemplo la palabra auto
allá por el 1800 su creador tuvo que
ponerle un nombre porque si no hubiera
sido muy difícil vender esa cosa con
ruedas que sirve para transportar gente
objetos
sin embargo si yo hoy les digo que tengo
un automóvil ustedes me van a preguntar
cuál pero no me van a decir qué es eso
otra característica del lenguaje aparte
de esta de crear o de identidad una cosa
es que también limita
y les voy a contar por qué
hace algunas semanas atrás fui al
almacén y había un perro había muchos
perros pero había uno que me llamó
muchísimo la atención
el perrito está en cuestión tenía sólo
dos patas delanteras
y tendrían que ver como corría a la par
de sus compañeros de hogar
y sabes por qué este perro podía correr
igual que nosotros de cuatro patas
porque nadie nadie nadie le dijo que le
faltaban dos patas
él sabía que tenía dos y fue por eso que
podía correr
por eso digo que los límites están en el
lenguaje
el perrito tuvo suerte porque no la
entendió a la dueña cuando le dijo que
así no iba a poder caminar
pero nosotros los humanos y que
entendemos cuando nos dicen que no
podemos que es imposible
que sin piernas no se puede caminar
los invito a conectar un momento con el
niño que alguna vez fueron
recuerdan qué cosas les gustaban
que querían ser grandes
que los hacía felices
y qué cosas les daban miedo
y recuerdan quién fue esa persona que
les dijo que no iban a poder ser o hacer
eso que deseaban o que imaginaban
porque les puedo asegurar que fue con
todo el amor del mundo que le dijeron
que eso era imposible
y fue ahí que apareció el límite
se grabó en su lenguaje en nuestro
lenguaje
lo vimos por cierto y dejamos de soñar
pues asombra la magnitud que tiene el
lenguaje
y entonces qué lugar le damos en nuestra
vida en nuestra familia
tomamos conciencia de las cosas que le
decimos a nuestros chicos
cómo se las decimos cuál es el propósito
de decirlo
pensamos alguna vez antes de
verbalizarlo cómo va a repercutir eso en
él o en ella si el límite es nuestro
pues de ellos
si era para tanto lo que pasó si se
merecía que le digan que es un inútil
que no sirve que no puede
nos damos cuenta el impacto que eso
genera en un niño
y el que generó en nosotros
y el qué
generando
podemos ver como el límite apareció
primero en el lenguaje y después
actuamos en forma coherente con esa
limitación que nos pusimos tenemos mucho
para reflexionar
es que tan fundamental es el lenguaje en
nuestra vida
tan importante
que no es transparente
como si fuera un par de anteojos que
están posados en la nariz sabemos que
están
pero no lo vemos
y como digo siempre hasta que no lo
vemos no podemos modificarlo
y es lógico que no lo hayamos visto
porque forma parte de nuestros modelos
el primer paso para modificar
cualquier situación que nos incomode a
cualquiera y pasar de lea
molestia a tu poder tomar las acciones
para modificarla es verla
con verla
me refiero a permitirnos sentir esa
incomodidad esa duda esa molestia que
nos hace pensar si estará bien o no lo
que estamos haciendo
les cuenta una pequeña historia yo estoy
en pareja hace 18 años
una vida
como se imaginarán en todos estos años
la pareja fue modificándose
ya nada queda de esos chicos bueno a mí
me quedó el cuerpo en realidad
en fin que siempre me cuestiona esto de
nunca parar de cuestionarlo todo me dice
nunca te alcanza
y yo le digo no
la idea es justamente esa siempre buscar
un poco más para ingresar en zonas que
no serán sueños hasta ese momento y esto
no se trata del conformismo sino de
permitirnos dudar de todo todo el tiempo
aún si creo que estoy en lo cierto me lo
vuelvo a preguntar
y esta duda permanente este
cuestionamiento esa incomodidad eso es
lo que nos aleja de las certezas y nos
empuja a crecer
pensemos ahora en el lenguaje con esta
nueva mirada de cuestionarlo todo
imaginemos juntos
como sería un día de cualquiera de
nosotros
nos levantamos temprano llamamos a los
chicos para ir al colegio preparamos el
desayuno
desayunamos
y a la escuela
cuando lo buscamos nosotros
todos entendemos un poco de comunicación
efectiva y entonces arrancamos un
interrogatorio
cómo te fue en el colegio y qué hiciste
nada que es nada y jugué me aburre un
poco con quién jugaste con mario con
pedro comiste
sí
terminada esta conversación podemos
sentirnos plenos y felices de haber
terminado nuestra labor de padres
a casa y a comer rápido rápido porque
ellos se quieren ir a jugar y nosotros
queremos seguir trabajando a la tarde
las actividades diarias
y al finalizar volvemos a casa y arranca
el ritual del baño no sé si se dieron
cuenta
pero en mi ejemplo
hay varios rituales que son comunes a
todas las familias
el llevar y traer a los chicos el
despertar y el desayuno
el baño y hasta siempre hay un momento
reservado para los dibujitos y los
juegos
pero no hay tiempo para el lenguaje
y con esto me refiero al tiempo para
brindarles a nuestros hijos
conversaciones de calidad que generen
intimidad y confianza en el vínculo
y a ver yo ya sé que esto que planteo es
complejo a mí también me pasa
que llega a la noche y me doy cuenta que
más allá del tiempo compartido en el
auto de llevar y traer
no hubo conversación pero también en
esos casos puedo hacerme cargo que algo
no genere ese día pero si puedo hacerlo
mañana
observaremos en los que nos da la
posibilidad de corregir eso que no nos
gusta
lo que nos incomoda
conversaciones como las que les conté
recién en el auto donde nuestros niños
son interrogados son los más frecuentes
prácticamente nunca se nos ocurre como
adultos
y empezar la conversación contándole que
fue de nuestro día cuáles son nuestras
penas nuestras alegrías
y rompimos en la vida de los chicos con
preguntas que a ellos no les generan
ningún tipo de interés y que no fomentan
el vínculo
pensemos nosotros qué nos pasaría si
vamos caminando nos cruzamos con un
vecino y nos empiezo a preguntar y
preguntar y preguntar pero no nos cuenta
nada
lo más probable es que esa relación no
pase nunca al estadio de amistad porque
es realmente muy difícil generar
relación con alguien que solamente está
dispuesto a preguntar pero no quiere
compartir de nada
en nuestro afán por proteger a nuestros
niños terminamos les vendiendo un cuento
que no es en donde parece ser que
nosotros los padres somos invencibles y
criamos chicos que creen que sus padres
nos lloran
y que cuando sean padres no van a llorar
porque no está en el modelo aceptado el
fracaso no está en el modelo aceptado y
criamos niños existís estás
que se frustran porque no alcanzan nunca
los estándares propuestos por los padres
cuando somos como son ellos adultos
nos damos cuenta que nos sentimos
incómodos y aparecen las preguntas
porque no me cuenta sus cosas
porque no cuenta conmigo
y la respuesta es cuántos años de no
relación existen entre ese adulto y vos
en qué momento creímos los padres que
por haber traído hijos al mundo la
relación auto mágicamente iba a fluir
la realidad es que no
y es como le dije en un comienzo el
lenguaje es tan cotidiano que no lo
vemos
y no le damos el lugar de importancia
que necesita por eso les digo
que una relación ha sido siempre de una
forma
no quiere decir que no pueda ser
modificada
está en nosotros
el momento es ahora
y la herramienta es el lenguaje
el lenguaje
y desune
construye y destruye
genera vínculos
pero también los elimina gracias
[Aplausos]